[Musique]
depuis près de trois ans maintenant les
vagues de covid-19 déferlent
unlassablement
les vagues se suivent mais ne se
ressemblent pas la vaccination a changé
la donne le virus lui s'adapte au début
de la pandémie le stress ov2 avait le
champ libre personne n'était immunisé il
circulait dans la population sans
rencontrer de résistance
mais l'arrivée des vaccins a réduit son
champ d'action sous la pression le virus
a changé de nouveaux variants sont
apparus plus contagieux il a réussi à
contourner notre immunité pendant les
premières vagues de covid un seul
variant de
la vague Delta aujourd'hui le portrait
est différent
en janvier dernier c'est au Picron qui
s'est engouffré il est devenu le seul
variant en circulation et il a fait des
petits au micro-ondes à vitesse grand V
Béa
5 des à 5.1 et à 5.1.1 et ainsi de suite
en tout des centaines de descendants ont
été identifiés dans la famille au
micro-ondes c'est le sous-varien ba-5
qui prend le plus de place cet automne
quelle version du virus lui succédera
deux candidats potentiels au nom tout
aussi poétiques BQ un point 1 descendant
de B5 ou encore un proche parent xbb on
les surveille de près quand les
premières études suggèrent qu'ils
pourraient échapper fortement à notre
immunité acquise grâce au vaccin et aux
infections préalables des scientifiques
les surnomme pentagones parce qu'il
comporte au moins 5 mutations qui leur
permettent de mieux s'accrocher pour
infecter nos cellules mais une nouvelle
vague pourrait aussi être provoquée par
un nouveau venu un Variant encore
inconnu
difficile donc de prédire ce qui nous
attend d'abord à cause du grand nombre
de variants qui circulent et de la
vitesse à laquelle il se répandent aider
par le relâchement des mesures
sanitaires
on le sait le terrain du virus est
planétaire
certains souvent riens ont émergé dans
des endroits où les populations sont peu
vaccinées c'est ce qui fait dire à
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé
l'OMS qu'à moins d'y remédier il restera
une faille que le virus pourra exploiter
pour ces raisons l'OMS maintient son
niveau d’alerte maximale il est encore
trop tôt pour baisser la garde d'autant
qu'on ne sait pas encore avec certitude
à quel point les vaccins nous protègent
contre cette panoplie de sous variant
en revanche on sait déjà qu'il résiste à
plusieurs traitements qui étaient
efficaces au début de la pandémie contre
les premiers variants qui ont circulé
le futur nous réserve-t-il d'autres
tempêtes ou alors une mère sans trop de
houle ponctuée de vaguelettes la réponse
est encore en